Pat do you ever wake up and miss playing with
Nirvana or are those days so far behind you?
You know every once in a while me and
Chris and Dave get together and we do play
as if we're Nirvana and it's ... Oh you do?
Really? So I don't have to miss it We do it dave
i didn't mean if we're in the same town together
or you know whatever we'll get together and job
you mean you'll get where do you get together
in a rehearsal space well last time we did it
at the house where we recorded the album oh no
kidding yeah we actually recorded some stuff yeah
do you ever go back and listen to the nirvana
albums either you two guys do you go back and
say you know i just want to go live that
over again no no is it too painful yes yes
in other words emotionally it pains you because
when you hear it it brings back every memory of
recording or touring or whatever it just makes
me sad it's hard sometimes yeah i mean there's
times where you're driving in the car and like a
song will come on last night actually my daughter
harper she's 11. she's like dad can we just go
drive around she's been stuck in the house for
weeks she's like let me just drive around i was
like yeah sure so we jump in the car in my van uh
this cool old ford van from the 60s and we just
drove around like drove around the hollywood
looked at it was like eight o'clock at night
just driving around and come as you are came
on the radio and she started singing she's saying
every word wow i've never played her that record
we don't like talk about nirvana and stuff and
she was singing every word to the song i was like
that that to me that feels good do the kids ask
you about nirvana do they say dad what was that
she actually did for the first time last night
yeah it was a trip she wanted to know if kurt was
shy i think yeah i was like yeah he kind
of was she and then she said was he shy
around people he didn't know or was he also
shy around people he did know and i it was
interesting it was really the first time she
started really asking me questions about kurt
that was a first and uh it was great it was okay
and you know why that's such a good question
because most of us don't understand someone who
is shy but yet could go up in front of thousands
that is exactly what she said that is
exactly what my daughter said last night
she goes it's so strange that he could
be so shy but then stand up on stage and
play music in front of thousands of
people that's exactly what she said